безлюдні вулиці та покинуті будинки які
вже 37 років занепадають без своїх
господарів з кожним днем Чорнобиль
дедалі більше перетворюються на дикі
хащі офіційно Чорнобиль місто зі
статусом без населення але люди тут все
ще живуть це самосели приміром Ось у
цьому заквітченому подвір'ї мешкає
Михайло шилан
Добрий день Доброго здоров'я пану
Михайло 85 третину свого життя він
прожив тут
мира вулиця Миру 47
здавалося що після аварії на ЧАЕС нова
Біда не ступить на ці землі але спочатку
повномасштабного вторгнення РФ сюди
прийшли російські загарбники 24 лютого
2022 року в окупацію потрапила АЕС а
невдовзі й саме місто Чорнобиль Тут у
мене було
герб український прапор
[__] приїхали сюди так вот вони ж тут
були таке позакрашував за день до
їхнього приходу так уже позакрашував як
є тобі в мене поняли чи ні злякався
приводу з
розстріляють мене за що за про що
росіяни оселилися в сусідньому будинку
за яким вже багато років доглядає пан
Михайло
цю хату
Я кажу хлопці я вам ключі
не надо нам ваше ключей у нас свої ключі
автоматами прикладами підбивали замки
там пробої погнути повибивали двері
перевернули все на світі пане Михайло
складно навіть пересуватися не те що
захищатися Утім рідної домівки не
покинув
діти мене забирали Ну я в принципі не
пішов що він мені зробив б'є чогось ним
там діду
сі гава дитинство пан Михайло навіть
створив імпровізований історичний музей
на своєму подвір'ї це головна гордість
господаря вони єли консерви Ну щоб вас
був було уявлення
43-й год можете понижати показати йому в
этот
пан збирав власноруч переважно після
паводків на берегах річок прип’ять та уж
Ну тут зараз я не тато ж Їздив по гриби
поету рибу була в лютому
це буржуйка я її знайшов на березі річки
Прип'ять під ляльок там я лови рибу з
вудочкою і найшов бачите воду щоб ви
бачили серед експонатів їй найдорожче
серцю речі зовсім не пов'язані з війною
моя Паша романовна
любительница работу таких
Паша Романівна покійна дружина самосела
у 2000 році подружжя вирішило
повернутися доживати віку у рідному
Чорнобилі
я на 10 год молодшу жінку взяв щоб на
чужих дівчат
а вона заболіло та й поганою хворобою і
умерла вже я
пішли 15 років сам
це ми ваші Романов в неї жінки квіточки
вона посадила Я вже тоді докидаю
пан Михайло з особливим трепетом
розповідає про все що пов'язано з
покійною дружиною і дуже просив показати
глядачам Deutsche Welle квіти які
посадила його покійна дружина знаєш
донька ти пока Я буду
отам познімайте мої квіти
втрату дружини Він переживає й досі тож
для нього справжнім шоком стала
поведінка російських військових які
залізли в домовину
А жінка як моя вмерла Так я заказав тут
в Чорнобилі то
гроба а діти привезли вже ж із Києва як
їхали на похорони то привезли свого і ти
Гром лежить у тому то хліву Ну бачите
той гроб Там стоїть
і така цапня
то Того гроба перевернув і одкрили що
вже можна шукати в тому грабує
що вам шукав у гробу смерть наверно свої
шукав Після пережитого Богдан Михайло
певен тепер ніщо не вижене його з Рідної
оселі і скільки б діти не намагалися
його забрати до себе самого селрішуче
відмовляється з моїм контактами з моїми
баляжками кому я надо
вони мене забирають Ні я не хочу
моє квіточки моя Паша посадила квіточки
Ото все вона попертягувала мене це
тримає
близько пів
сотні Люди які пережили аварію на
Чорнобильській АЕС евакуацію але все
одно попри заборону жити на цих
територіях вирішили повернутися це ж мій
Чорнобиль я заради нього і приїхала може
і я і не жила тому що я зрозуміла що без
нього не виживу і ніщо й ніколи мені не
замінить якщо я на день їхала в Київ Чи
ще кудись то мені здавалось що з моїм
Чорнобилем щось сталося
саме тому через 10 років після аварії на
ЧАЕС Валентина Кухаренко повернулася до
рідного Чорнобиля і навіть росіяни які
торік прийшли з війною не змусили літню
жінку покинути домівку пані Валентина
вірила що українські військові визволять
Чорнобиль тому каже за своє життя навіть
не хвилювалась
ось летять ракети і ми їх рахуємо 9 штук
11 Це ж ми знали що вони полетіли і що
чиєсь життя закінчиться ми плакали з
донькою А за себе якось не боялися
понад місяць окупації самосели прожили
без води світла зв'язку і під постійним
прицілом російських снайперів
Ось на цій будівлі лежали снайпери
проходити звісно Було дуже страшно вони
цілими днями там лежали ну дякуючи Богу
все обійшлося просто треба ще жити
напевно
спогади про окупацію даються пані
Валентині не
легко
хочеш
війна Росії проти України вже торкнулася
її родини
у дружини мого Онука рідний брат загинув
5 березня жодних повідомлень лише
повідомили що вони не повернулися із
завдання а він був десь на фронті
попри все у своїй 84 пані Валентина
вірить у перемогу України і мріє дожити
щоб побачити її На власні очі а для
антистресу від жахіть війни завела котів
кожен із них має окреме ліжко й постійно
увагу господині
[музика]
можеш Да да да так хорошо
з кожним роком самоселів у
Чорнобильській зоні стає дедалі менше
але не тому що тутешні мешканці звідси
виїжджають Вони настільки прив'язані до
цієї землі що попри радіацію і окупацію
обрали доживати свій вік у місті яке вже
майже зруйноване